foreign
let's go out to Sean in Moses Lake
what's up Sean
how you doing John partying man what are
you up to
oh not much just about ready to get the
day started here I figured I'd talk to
you first
my wife figures the exact opposite on
most mornings so good for you man good
for you what's up
um all right well I got myself in a
little bit of a situation here okay
um I'll give you a quick backstory real
quick um so I had a alcohol withdrawal
related seizure September 21
and I have no legal trouble or anything
like that
um so then my grandpa so I quit after
that and then my Grandpa died February
22. jeez so I started slowly coming back
and doing what I'm not supposed to be
doing and then so uh November of
uh 22 to December of 22 I went to
treatment in California
came back was doing good through the
holidays IOP a Celebrate Recovery
counseling with my wife Lexi
um but then I started to relapse like
every three to four weeks just like
single day single night relapses and
not really understanding why until
afterwards and that pushed Lexi and Owen
my son to her mom's house we still are
cordial and see each other quite often
but they're in town and I'm out we have
20 acres out here in little farm
and um so my two questions are is
could you help me understand what like I
I after all this treatment that I've
been to I still am not understanding
until I'm not noticing what I just did
until at like the next day like why the
hell did I do that
you know and then the second question is
I'm really a relationship oriented guy
and I've been with Lexi for over 17
years now
so how should I deal with that loss of
communication with her without going
stir crazy out here by myself yeah it's
a great question man
um so you're my dog my dog Rossi and she
doesn't speak very good English
yeah but she probably loves you more
than more than most
um
and you've been through hell the last
year or two huh
yeah
and you've been held through hell way
before that too huh
yeah but it was never like I said I've
had no legal problems I was I don't care
about that I don't care about that I
don't care about that okay there's a lot
of people who
are in the nerd world we call it long
tail suicide
who are quietly drinking themselves to
death and no one will ever know because
they're gonna say I got pancreatic
cancer I had liver issues or I had a
stroke
and no one's going to realize that for
the last 30 years they quietly
um drown themselves in the company of
people who loved them
yeah so I don't care about legal trouble
man I care about Sean who's sitting in
front of me
who's looking at his life and and has a
different picture of what this could
look like man and you just feel Tethered
to the old one right
yeah
so
I
my instinct is to call bullcrap on
in a loving way right if we're sitting
here be smiling but I would say I call
bullcrap on
I just black out and I wake up the next
day and I was drunk the night before
there's always a moment yeah and
like and it's it's their and I know that
like
these situations they just kind of pop
up out of the blue I know it's not an
excuse but you know what sets you off
what is it
um I want to say like my like friendship
if like a friend's coming over or
something like that you know
relationships
and so if I wanted if a friend is coming
over if your wife wants to to get close
with you that's when you drink
well I mean I'll have friends like I
just went to Dallas for five days and
didn't drink the whole time I was down
there sure because it's a new
environment yeah yeah and I
and like I say it's just it's for me
it's answer my question though brother
when you're sitting here what happened
but friendship are you drinking because
you're lonely are you drinking cause you
got friends coming up I think I think I
think because I'm because I'm bored
there you go yeah
and like uh like my old routines of like
out on the tractor having a beer in my
hand you know that that type of thing
that's right
so all the things you just rattled off
Celebrate Recovery AAA counseling with
my wife trying to do this trying to do
that
you are trying to do so much all at the
exact same time
yeah I would love to see you
back out a little bit
and have One Singular goal for six
months and that is to stay Stone sober
we're not going to also dig into my
childhood past we're not going to also
dig into how can I communicate better
not going to dig into the shame
associated with you love this woman for
17 years but you've dragged her through
the mud too
We're not gonna do any of that
we're going to create a structure around
staying sober
because what you're trying to do man
it's like you have a stomach virus and
you keep throwing up and you're also
trying to clean up the house at the same
time and meet with a roofing contractor
and test out new counter wipes the first
thing you got to do man is quit barfing
right
yeah and that's that's the challenge
and yes
um
it doesn't surprise me that it's easy
for you when you're in a new environment
to stay clean because your body doesn't
fall into those old rhythms the the
challenge you gotta you got to be honest
with yourself about is a
and I live on some makers too and so I
get what I'm asking you is that the
place for you
well see that's the that's one thing too
we were uh
um my wife Lexi she's a consultant
pharmacist and she has an opportunity to
move to St George in Utah and we're
seriously thinking about a new
environment
I don't know that that's necessarily A
Bad Thing
yeah
and maybe it's something where you hang
on to your property and y'all go down
there and rent for a season
yeah we're we've been talking through
that the last couple weeks okay
do
your wife has to understand and believe
that healing is coming but you can't do
it all at the same time and she's going
to want to get her 17 years back
yeah and she's going to want to get
especially the last two or three years
back and she wants to get back how
scared she was when you had that seizure
and she wants to get back all that right
now and this is not how healing works
yeah
and like
and it makes me feel terrible I know it
does but that starts the cycle over
again
yeah
you feel terrible and then your body's
way of dealing with terrible is to
unplug when you unplug you get bored man
and I gotta feel something
I don't want to feel shame and I can
feel this and this is awesome
is that fair okay yeah that's fair
and you know it's uh what keep what
keeps you from calling your sponsor
um I don't have a sponsor yet I call my
buddies to keep me me Focus today
really that ends today
you have to get a sponsor to hold you
accountable
okay bro your way has not worked it's
not worked has it I know nope
you gotta say for the next 60 days I'm
going to AAA every single day and I will
get a sponsor and I'm gonna go through
the whole rigmaru as much as you roll
your eyes and oh my gosh it's so stupid
and they get on your face or whatever
they want to sing Kumbaya whatever they
want to do
that's the way because my Way's not
working
yeah
because I I mean I was doing AAA every
day and
but then I just kind of got out of that
Rhythm you did you did it part way
yeah you went to meetings but you didn't
connect with people right
I kind of dad was there probably going
for three or four months you know you
never got somebody's number to call when
you felt the need to use no yeah no you
just you you were playing it hey you
went halfway
okay
and here's the thing I think you're like
just talking to you I think you're
probably a great guy are you good dad
yeah I try to be when I can when I'm
around him yeah
but you know your wife's doing what's
best for him she took she got her away
from somebody who's not got him away
from somebody's not safe right
right I understand all that it's just
hard on me oh dude I can't I can't my
son's at Camp right now I can't even
breathe our whole house is a little bit
low because because one of uh one of the
gangs gone right I get that yeah yeah
but listen you can't get sober for him
I know for myself
why don't you believe that dude
I I don't know I feel like
like it's hard not to like defend my
family
I know but the best way to defend your
family is you being able to defend your
family
yeah I know
who told you Sean sucks
uh
I thank him
your son
no me oh yeah but somebody
let's start those those kind of
conversations start as somebody else's
words
um
I mean I couldn't tell you that off the
top of my head when I would have ever
noticed that
okay
the way it usually works is we're born
into a family of some sort we're born
into some sort of
it's just the air we breathe when you
would know it I and that's that's that
could be another topic here is I
I mean I have one brother no divorces my
parents been more married for 40 years
never moved same Elementary School all
that Sports football basketball baseball
I didn't drink till freshman year at
college and that was just barely on and
off
so what is it you thought life would
look like now
and what's different about this reality
no I know but let's take drinking off
the table
you thought your life would look like
something
did it include driving a tractor on your
own little place
yep
so what's so Hollow about this world
uh right now
um not having my family home
I know dude but there's a hollowness
there that you wallpaper over with
alcohol
even if your family's sitting right
inside
that's what I haven't been able to
figure out
because you're really really focused on
external metrics haven't been to jail
they're still married for 40 years I
know a lot of silently abusive families
where everything looks great on the
outside
or a really really great moms and dads
who did the best they could
but they also let one kid know that they
like the other kid better I don't know
what your story is man yeah so that that
is one thing that I've I I kind of
noticed that my punishments were harsher
than my brothers okay but
where is that buried and why did it come
out when it did if that is what I think
that's a problem if I were you I'd want
to know the answer to that but you can't
know that answer until you get sober
right and so going spelunking into your
past trying to fix all things mayor dude
you're doing so much all at the same
time
I want to see you make a full commitment
a full run
I'd go into meetings
for 60 let's do 90 days three months man
give you oh love Sean enough for three
months
and I'm gonna get a sponsor on the first
day and tell them I've been before I
didn't do it all the way I didn't go all
in yeah I need someone I can call
and what we're going to do is we're
going to practice we're going to make it
commitment to sobriety and it will be on
that Foundation that we can start
becoming working on practicing becoming
a better husband and Dad
all right but you got to get clean
do you trust me when I tell you you're
worth you're worth more than this
oh yeah I mean I've heard it a bunch of
times it's just I'm
felt like reaching out to to you guys
this something different for me to think
about I'm grateful for you man how can I
help you
is there something you need uh-huh
I don't think so not right I mean I'd
like to like
talk to you again okay
oh it would make my heart full if after
60 days you would call me back and let
me know you've been going for 60 days
and I'll have you back on the show we'll
do a whole segment is that cool
that's awesome okay that's that's uh
that's our that's our deal brother you
uh you go make it happen and we'll have
you back and by the way
if you have two or three relapses over
that 60 days I still want you back man
you're in the gang now
you're in the gang I'll walk with you
for the Long Haul but you gotta have
people that you trust right next to you
that will call you out your buddies
aren't cutting him your buddies aren't
cutting him thank you for loving
yourself and your wife and your son
let's go get sober first and we'll work
on the other stuff next